good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia and i am proud to welcome
you to this edition of our 2021 2022 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series this
lecture series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia the uva
brain institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the national institutes of general medical
sciences this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
we'll enjoy presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences our selected participants for
our biomedical data science innovation lab program
will leverage these presentations as a vital as
vital material for our culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held here
in historic charlottesville virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data science
innovation lab program are being accepted until
january 31st 2022 so please consider applying and
or encouraging your junior colleagues to do so we
look forward to reviewing their applications it
is my honor and privilege today to welcome our
speaker dr randall moorman is professor of
medicine biomedical engineering and medical
physiology as well as biophysics bio biological
physics here at the university of virginia
randall moormon was educated at the university
of mississippi and at school of medicine and
trained clinically at duke university he's been a
cardiologist at uva since 1990 and is the founding
director of the uva center for advanced medical
analytics formerly he was the chief medical
officer of amp 3d a company which provides
extensible software as a service platforms
for predictive analytics processing big data
from physiological monitors health records
lab tests and more in real time and at a glance
enabling proactive interventions improved outcomes
and cost savings throughout a patient's entire
hospital state emp 3d is now a nihon koden company
as a recent development in continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science seminar
series theme randall's lecture today is entitled
predictive analytics monitoring at the bedside
there's been a lot of discussion about these
days about how artificial intelligence big
data machine learning and deep learning are
revolutionizing health care by predicting clinical
illnesses like sepsis and investigators at the
uva center for advanced medical informatics
have been working this area for about 20 years
they've gained many insights and randall is going
to share some of that work with us today make
suggestions for the next generation of researchers
and give pointers for telling what approaches are
most likely to be most helpful for patients and
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube and if you're watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are highly
encouraged to submit any questions for dr moormon
by the chat feature in their zoom sessions i'll
synthesize all these questions and ask them on
your behalf at the last 10 minutes or so of dr
norman's lecture and with that welcome randall we
are so excited to have you um and we're looking
forward to your lecture well jack thanks very
much and i certainly appreciate the invitation
today i'm going to take the opportunity to give
a narrative account of the long story of our
involvement in predictive analytics monitoring
i'm going to go back to how how this story all
started it's not something that we revisit much in
our day-to-day work and it was fun for me to put
this talk back together again aft after some years
a couple of important things on on the title slide
here when i say on behalf of many i'm not kidding
we've been working in this field for more than
20 years at uva there aren't enough slides to
put down all the names of people who have made
very significant contributions along the way
i'll point to a couple of names as i go through
but i won't in any way do justice to the the
many works of the many people that have had their
hands in this another thing to point out jack has
already mentioned did is that previously i was
the chief medical officer of the small company
in charlottesville that was spun up out of lice
the licensing adventures group that was acquired
over the summer by a larger company neon coden
which is a japanese maker of medical monitoring
devices and i draw attention to this because as
you might guess doing work in a vacuum or garage
can be very gratifying but only up to a point and
to have the kind of impact on the world that you
wish to have it is imperative that you understand
the commercialization process and and work in that
arena as well and believe me the nuances and
challenges on the business side of the things
that i'm going to be talking about are every bit
as complicated and gnarly as the computers and
the mathematics and especially the clinical excuse
me the clinical issues involved so so to go back
to the beginning in the 1990s early 1990s i and
the people that i was working with at the time
thought to ourselves that this is probably a true
statement that there are detectable signatures of
illness in continuous monitoring data i think
most most clinicians doctors and nurses that
take care of patients would agree with that that
kind of statement as well but the newness of the
idea was that the detection of these signatures
in real time in real life could change things
by leading to early detection and early to treat
early treatment of patients with some illnesses
and possibly to improved outcomes and i'll point
to this as being a new idea that was generated
here all that time ago this new idea like many
new ideas went through an evolution that was
first put forward by the philosopher arthur
schopenhauer that there's three stages first a
new idea or a new truth is ridiculed second it
is violently opposed and third it is accepted
as being self-evident and this kind of cynical
point of view of the world in fact turns out to
be almost exact i think exactly correct but we've
been gratified to see that we've made it all the
way through and now everybody generally agrees
with without this idea that early detection of
signatures of illness might be a good thing didn't
used to be that way in any event we began this
story back in the 1990s working on the problem
of neonatal sepsis that is to say bloodstream
bacterial infection in premature infants in the
neonatal icu and to say that the diagnosis of this
illness is difficult is a massive understatement
so if if i asked you is this baby septic
your question in return might be what baby
so it turns out that under this covered crib
there does indeed lie a baby weighing a couple of
pounds maybe three pounds very hard to understand
from from looking at that patient even when you
get up close and personal as to whether that
that infant is having symptoms of illness or
signs of illness but sepsis is a bad thing
with potentially catastrophic uh consequences and
so doctors and nurses are forever wondering about
whether their patients are septic and then doing
tests now a blood draw an adult is no big deal but
to draw two or three cc's of blood from an infant
whose circulating blood volume is 70 or 80 cc's
especially if you want to draw more than one
test well that's a major consideration about
whether or not to do any tests or not and as as a
result of the suspicion of this bacterial illness
antibiotics are given a lot to infants at any
moment in our nicu through the years about about
a third of infants at any moment are receiving
antibiotics because of suspected or proven
sepsis so a dire problem difficult to diagnose
is there a signature of illness well in 1959
i fed i found a paper from 1959 that that had that
pointed in one direction changes in heart size
in the disney newborn baby well it isn't the hard
size that was interesting in in this paper it was
interesting about it was uh observations about the
heart rate so he talks here about the the speed of
the heart rate but he makes this this statement
right here a characteristic finding at the height
of respiratory distress and within a few hours of
the onset of the illness was a fixed rate between
100 and 10 120 beats a minute that did not vary if
the baby cried or was roused to physical activity
there follows some nonsense about heart
sounds but then we get down to the bottom here
when they survived early signs of improvement
where a rise in the heart rate that's fine or
a liability of the rate as shown by variations in
it with exertion so this was a big clue that the
pattern of the heart rates might hold information
at the time that we started in this started with
this work there was a decade or so of research
into heart rate variability in adults with heart
disease so this seemed like a likely place to go
looking so sure enough after we figured out how
to make measurements we made long recordings of
ekgs and determined heart rates from infants in
the neonatal icu and what i'm showing you here is
not a plot of heart rate but a plot of the times
in between heart beats and so this is upside down
heart rate slow rates up here 500 milliseconds
in between beats is a heart rate of 120 beats per
minute fast heart rates down here 300 milliseconds
per heartbeat is a heart rate of 200 but there's a
very there was no matter how you plot it there's a
excuse me a very striking difference between an
infant at the height of his or her illness and
after successful recovery yes there was
a bit of a difference in the heart rate
but it is the variation of that heart rate that
is very strikingly different now it doesn't take
a lot of statistical or mathematical prowess
to be able to tell that time series from that
time series and and we worked a lot on that but
but just to put some things in context here's
our paper from 1994 and here we're showing
a neural network based on polynomial nodes
to distinguish the heart rate patterns of
the sick baby from the heart rate patterns
of the well baby so you know neural networks have
been around longer than than than our work but it
as new as all those techniques might appear to you
to be in point of fact they're pretty well founded
and have been around for a long time so the
upshot of this was that this particular technique
and other techniques as well did did a very robust
job of distinguishing babies early in the course
of their illness day one from after recovery
over here and so we we crystallized our new
idea a little bit better down here at the bottom
the new idea is that the signatures of illness
with respect to neonatal sepsis low heart rate
variability and so we set out to find out more
about that and when we fashioned tools to make
long recordings and actually look at the ekg
signal here a few heartbeats from from an infant
up here and then rather longer time series of the
time in between heartbeats here and we knew what
was happening with the infants and so we could
match what we knew clinically with what our eye
told us about the patterns here so this is what
normal neonatal heart rate variability looks
like over about a 25 minute stretch of time
and ekg aficionados will note that this is
sinus rhythm which is essentially the only
heart rhythm that the newborn infants have they
aren't really plagued by cardiac arrhythmias
okay so here's an infant who was several
hours before the clinical diagnosis of sepsis
that is to say baby for all intents and purposes
was clinically fine but a few hours from now is
going to be diagnosed with with that dire illness
and so what what about our new idea about reduced
heart rate variability well okay well sure enough
through here here's a stretch of 10 minutes or
something of heart rate variability this certainly
lower than what i just showed you a second ago
but lo and behold here are these other things now
this is still the time between heartbeats so from
time to time there are some long intervals that
is to say that the heart slows down some during
during these times it's a very striking looking
thing to look at a flat line with spikes going up
in it this is to say that the rhythm remains sinus
rhythm that is to say normal rhythm here we are
same baby a little bit later and now this is
very strikingly different from normal and yes
if you look if you can find a quiet baseline the
variability is very much different what than what
i showed you before but here are deceleration
after deceleration after deceleration now the
heart the the bradycardia alarm is at about the
top of the screen so i'm showing you some very
pronounced examples ones that would have in fact
triggered the alarm at the bedside but that's not
always the case and here are some perfectly good
decelerations over here that got nowhere near
the alarm threshold and there were many many of
these as well in what we looked at those of you
interested in cardiac electrophysiology what's
happening is these are sinus pauses there's no
evidence for overt sinus exit block there's no
evidence for av nodal slowing the mechanism of
this as much as i like to think i know about this
kind of thing is not totally known to me but the
phenomenology is blindingly clear here now we set
out to to get mathematical measures to distinguish
these things i'm sorry here's here's another
example may have been this example in fact so
heart rate variability a week before the diagnosis
of sepsis this is about a 25 minute record here
a few hours before here the the the bradycardia
alarm would be way up here and then as as before
the perfectly storming appearance of heart rate
decelerations against this backdrop of reduced
variability so our methods for quantifying this
we're centered around the idea that the histograms
of the of the heartbeat intervals would look
different between the normal and abnormal
episodes and so if you conceive of a normal
record here is one as being composed of many
small accelerations this again is time between
heartbeats along with many small decelerations
then the histogram turns out to be if not exactly
gaussian at least certainly bell-shaped with
representations on both sides of the median so
looked at in this way the abnormal record presents
itself as a very abnormal looking histogram so
here are the decelerations here and so now there's
a fat tail on this part of the histogram and i
hadn't drawn attention to it previously but the
accelerations have all been clipped off and so the
half of the histogram that reflects accelerations
is truncated on that side now some of you may have
been reflecting upon the fact that this heart rate
pattern reduced variability and decelerations
is precisely the pattern that clinicians that
are delivering babies on the on the in the
labor and delivery suite are looking for
in the heart rate patterns of the fetus and this
idea reduced variability with decelerations is a
mantra up there that it's time to do an emergent
emergency cesarean section that is a time honored
practice 100 of fetuses are monitored in that way
in the bigger hospital certainly it's true at our
hospital and cesarean sections are the decisions
are made based on picking up strips of paper from
the floor eyeballing it looking for this pattern
and then saying go so it shouldn't be surprising
that that a a premature infant who by rights
should still have been a fetus inside a uterus
should show distress with the same kind of heart
rate patterns now as part of working on this we we
got involved with the idea of measuring entropy of
in these heart rate time series this is too long a
story to go into now but suffice it to say that
that entropy in this domain from the non-linear
dynamical uh domain which is where we borrowed
the concept is a matter of looking for repeating
patterns and so in short as we examine this time
series we look for patterns that repeat themselves
tolerably well and let's just say that this we're
interested in this pair of green points and as we
scan everywhere else we find a tolerably similar
other pair of green points and now the question is
does the point that follows the red point
also match from the original over into here
and the more that that is true that is to
say the more to the more truth there is to
the idea that patterns repeat themselves
suggest that that the system is of low
entropy in the sense that it's not generating
new information as it goes along now after that
there there are some excuse me some details about
how you count things and how you calculate things
and we we uh found some difficulties with with
a current measurement and we developed our own
that we called sample entropy and that went on to
become something unto itself but is a good example
of the kind of time series mathematics that we
have used so through the years we we have kept
ourselves busy with adapting and optimizing and
developing new or new to the area mathematical
time series measures and this is a sort of
a narrative account of some number of them
and i'll be coming back to the last one the most
recent one um in a little bit sample entropy went
on to become a kind of a one-stop shop for chaos
theory in all fields uh at all times and and and
gathered some popularity okay so the way that
we we put together our mathematical measures
was using logistic regression and i'm sure you're
familiar with that from the the modern discussions
of machine learning and deep learning that to
do this you need a set of data from infants
that aren't sick you need another set of data
from infants r or at the time that they are
you label one set of data's outcome equals
zero you label the other outcome as outcome
outcome equals one and then you model the
log odds of the event as a straight line as
as a co coefficients times variables plus an
intercept and you end up by the time you back
out the probability with this familiar expression
here where you have exponentiated versions
of a linear combination of variables and those of
you that remember y equals mx plus b well that's
exactly what this is here is the intercept here is
the slope here is the variable it's multivariable
so so you can put more of these things in there
and when all was said and done we based our index
on four measures that we got from the time series
the standard deviation because sometimes the the
long records were quiet throughout two measures
from the histogram the acceleration based measure
and the deceleration based measure and this and
this entropy thing that i'm talking been telling
you about so we fit our logistic regression
model with all of our data and came out with
a measure that we could show clinicians that
reflected to them the probability of sepsis in
the next 24 hours now rather than give them
a give the clinicians a probability as such
we gave that gave them the fold increase in
the probability of the event with respect to
average thus and a normal infant hanging out in
the neonatal icu should have a score of one or
less average risk or lower than average risk an
advantage to using this this unit of measurements
which we have stuck with ever since is that it
makes for english language discussions about what
what the measure means so if i tell you that this
score is two that means your infant is twice as
likely as average to have an event and clinicians
can resonate with this this kind of thinking
so i'm showing you here 14 day records from two
of the infants this is from a paper in 2003. we're
up to there now um showing you every six hour
measurements of this score um on their in infants
on their way to to having having the diagnosis
of sepsis and the the diagnosis of sepsis on this
timeline is denoted by this acronym crash which
stands for cultures resuscitation and antibiotics
started here and what you can see from this
is in both of these cases that we selected
there were waves of increase of this score over
the days and days prior but there was certainly
evidence for increased risk prior to events now
the this score doesn't happen in a vacuum there
are a lot of other things happening to that infant
in the way of being on ventilatory support or
having central lines drugs other measurements
that people are making laboratory tests
and and so forth and so my colleague doug lake
with whom i worked closely since 2001 or two
started making these things that we have called
event maps that place on one visualization
the presence and the severity of abnormality
of events and measurements during the hospital
stay and superimposed is this score here we call
it the hrc index it's also called the hero score
but that here here it sits and here are its
units over to the side and this was a very
this is a very typical looking one where blood
cultures were drawn here antibiotics were given
here the diagnosis of sepsis was made here other
things were going on in the way of tachycardia and
temperature instability and whatnot and here's
a gratifying rise in the hero score prior to
the clinical diagnosis and this is the spirit
of the use of predictive analytics monitoring
at the bedside if a patient has a low risk that
rises then it makes sense to us for clinicians to
go see that patient and evaluate that patient
in the light of there is possibly a subacute
potentially catastrophic illness on its way so
about this time we applied for and were issued a
patent for the for this idea of early diagnosis
of subacute potentially catastrophic illness
and i draw attention to this simply because it
is the first step along the commercialization
pathway no company will undertake to manufacture
and distribute something that is in the public
domain i'm sorry that's true i didn't invent that
but that that is the hard truth of the matter
and so the commercial product that came out
is this which is the hero monitor it has run
continuously in the uva neonatal icu since the
spring of 2000 and uh since the fall of 2003 when
it when it got its first fda 510k clearance and
and this is the spirit of it here here is a low
score it's less than one here it has gone up at
this vertical yellow line here are the 30 minutes
of heart rate that were present at that time here
is reduced variability here are decelerations
it is a very robust and repeatable and repeating
signature of illness in that population
and since this since we're talking about history
that this is the first so far as i know premature
infant who was diagnosed with sepsis without
having any clinical illness to go along with it
so this was within the first week or two of
putting the hero monitor up in the uva nicu
here we are over 10 days and here goes the
score nicely less than one until it wasn't
and it rose to a value of something over two
here are the heart rate records that go with it
here we are a week prior let's call that normal
here we are at the time of of interest reduced
variability decelerations no great change in the
heart rate and then here we are after the fact
back to normal again so what happened was that
the the clinicians taking care of this infant
knew the story looked up on the wall saw an
increase in the hero score and undertook two to
evaluate the patient for sepsis so they looked
at the baby no no clinical signs of illness
they drew the usual suspect laboratories all of
them were normal except for one they sent a sample
of blood to the microbiology lab and and asked for
it to be cultured and sure enough 12 hours later
they received a call to say that the blood
was growing a gram-negative organism seratian
marscessons now the death rate in the nicu from
seratia sepsis is on the order of 40 4 out of 10
infants with with this diagnosis die as a
result of it in this case they got the blood
culture result back they could not ignore it
they started antibiotics hero score came down
and the baby not only didn't die the baby
never got sick now that is a remarkable
event an an infant who contracts an acute
infectious systemic illness where the death
rate is 4 out of 10 but it is diagnosed at a
time so early that they have not become ill
and rece and further receives appropriate therapy
on the spot the entire illness was averted that
is a wonderful story this galvanized all of this
that work in this field i got chills when they
called me from the nicu and told me about it i get
chills telling it to you today it is a remarkable
realization of the potential of what we can do
with data from patients to improve outcomes now
what i've just told you is is is a great story but
it is it is oh let me let me go ahead to say that
we looked at more patients that had this kind of
event that is to say a large abrupt increase in
the hrc index or hero score and what we found was
that fully half of them had an infection excuse me
infection that required treatment so this is the
positive predictive value it's 50 percent if you
haven't dealt with positive predictive values
for rare events let me explain let me tell you
that's a big number um in in contrast the
positive predicted value from my clinical world of
a treadmill test where everything goes wrong
with the patient that possibly could go wrong
the positive predictive value of that finding
for a heart attack in the next year is about 10
so this this positive predictive value of 48 is
a very big number indeed other infants that had
this finding had other kinds of illnesses um and
we were reassured from this that that was not a
one-time occurrence so to further hammer home
the question or answer the question of whether
this is going to help others and we undertook
a randomized clinical trial so this became by
the time it was over the largest randomized
trial ever undertaken in premature infants
i beg your point for this or any other reason
3 000 infants of less than 1500 grams birth
weight were randomized in nine neonatal
icus up and down the east coast and the
randomization was extremely simple um once the
infant got there and the parents signed consent
we either assigned them to have this risk shown
to clinicians or to receive only standard of care
and not have it displayed there were no mandated
interventions no one had to look at the monitor
let alone report on it let alone act on it there
were 3 000 infants more than 100 doctors more than
a thousand nurses the primary outcome measure had
to do was a it remains a popular sepsis related
outcome and we had other outcome measures in
particular in hospital mortality now the big
result from this trial was in one of the other
outcome measures and that was that there was
decreased mortality that is to say improved
survival when we showed the risk display to
clinicians these are survival curves over the
120 days after randomization that the trial
was designed to inspect here is the survival
of infants receiving conventional monitoring
their mortality that you're part of their
mortality over 120 days was little more than 10
which is exactly as expected from u.s national
statistics the mortality from the infants received
who had the new monitoring was eight and a bit
percent a relative reduction of something more
than twenty percent so twenty percent improved
survival from turning on a computer screen and
showing it to the people taking care of the baby
i'm not going to show you the results but we went
on to show that the the survival benefit was very
heavily concentrated in the infants who got septic
where the survival where the mortality rate fell
from 20 percent with conventional monitoring by
almost half to 12 in the infants that that had
the predictive monitoring as well so this is a a a
a wonderful result the paper was published
10 years ago as far as i know it remains
the largest randomized trial of of this kind it
will be superseded next year when we complete a
similar trial that's currently going on in
our cardiology award okay so that that is
was a flagship finding in the field and as
galvanized as i say us to continue to do
other work and now something let me give you some
examples of of that kind of thing as well but i'll
return at the end to to the to the infants again
okay so this is logistic regression we have used
other kinds of machine learning we are dabbling
our toe into deep learning at this point but one
interesting finding that's representative i think
of the kinds of findings that that an exploration
of different kinds of machine learning will bring
out is how different statistical models view
important variables in the clinical population so
this is a very this is a small segment of a bunch
of results from a similar study not a randomized
trial but a study that we did in the pediatric icu
where the range of age goes from 0 to 18 years
and we were interested again in the question
of sepsis and again we use predictive models
so what what i'm showing you here is is how
the method uh how the methodology can
lead to differences in the way that the
the variables are treated or looked at in the
overall statistical model now so here is the this
is the plot of the log of the odds as a function
of the age of the patient in the pediatric
icu down in the footnotes we're using restricted
cubic splines to get away from the fact that this
would have to be a monotonic straight line and
this is the story here okay and this these this
is the analytical result that comes back from the
fitted model but over here we used a random forest
model and we were struck by the difference in how
age was treated when you could look at it in this
much much much more granular kind of way using
random forest methodology and it resonated
clinically with those with the doctors up there
that they felt that this represented better what
they thought about and that is that infants in
the knee closer to the neonatal period had the
highest risk in in their unit not the finding
after you do the cubic spline kind of approach
but very much the finding over here if
you let the data drive the model now
as i've said we have moved on beyond the nicu
and in point of fact we have found that there are
signatures of illness everywhere i'm showing you
results here from a few years ago in a large study
that we conducted in our surgical icu and our
medical icu and we threw in nicu results over here
as well but this was to this was to establish the
idea that the signatures of different illnesses
might differ from each other and so here i'm
showing you what i'm calling a signature of
illness i'm going to draw attention to two of the
colored tiles to explain what i'm talking about
each of these is a plot of the law of gods as a
function of the measured variable and they all
come from multi-variable logistic regression
models and these log odds plots are from the
multi-variable model that is to say these are the
associated odds of of the illness given all of
the other variables are in the model at the same
time the way to interpret these kinds of plots are
for example this one which i've brought over and
expanded over here this is to say that the odds of
emergency intubation in the surgical icu go up
as the mean respiratory rate goes up patients
that are breathing faster are at higher risk of
requiring emergency intubation not a stunning
effect but that's that is the truth of the matter
so the this is colored orange because the risk
increases as the variable as the measured variable
increases and it's deeply huge because the p value
was very low here's the counter example we're now
talking about bleeding also in the surgical icu
and we're looking at the diastolic blood pressure
this is blown up over here as the diastolic blood
pressure is lower the risk of the event goes
up bleeding leads to low blood pressure we all
knew that coming in not a surprise but this is but
these are what i mean when you put them together
by signatures of illness and the way you
analyze this is you go stand across the room
you look at the respiratory models and you
say to yourself yes those look pretty similar
from what one adult icu to the next and then
you stand across the room and you look at
the hemorrhage models and you say yes they look
pretty similar from what one adult icu to the next
but wait a minute so here's sepsis now in adults
the signatures of illness do not look like each
other they look different in point of fact in
the in the medical icu sepsis presents more like
hemorrhage and the surgical icu sepsis presents
more like lung failure here's the neonatal icu
all of the signatures look the same same
diagnoses but now they look they all look
exactly like each other and none of them look
anything like that like what happens to adults
so this is to make the point that illnesses in
populations in hospital settings have signatures
that can differ from place to place it's a strong
argument against using a single predictive model
everywhere and so when we go to to introduce
predictive monitoring somewhere every unit has
its own models every target illness has its
own as well so i'm going to take you now to
oh i'm sorry now just one moment
i'm going to take you now to what what we are
currently doing in the icu's about displaying risk
uh to clinicians about patients what you're
looking at here is a comet monitor 35
of beds at the university of virginia hospital
have real-time predictive monitoring some of
those are the nicu and i've already shown you
that the rest of them have this thing that
we call as i say we call the comet plot and
i'm showing you now results from the uh from
old uh de-identified data real data real patients
i have no idea who and i actually have no idea
when these data were collected either so for this
unit we we elected to show the clinicians the
risk of sepsis again fold increase one two three
four five and also in hospital mortality and so
what we're showing you is every bed in the picu
the bed number is shown in the head of this
structure we call them comets because they look
like comets the tail of the comet is three hours
long so if you were an attending physician in
the pediatric icu and you walked in and saw this
one use case is that you don't stop walking and
you just direct your feet to beds 91 c 92 or 96
to see what is going on in there you don't go
in there armed with a diagnosis or a medication
or a plan your attention is drawn to those because
they are at high risk and in some cases increasing
risk the the the system is set up in such
a way that you can isolate a single patient
and look back over time to see is this a new
problem or a chronic problem or how just exactly
how long has all of this been going on and as
i say we have this available for a lot of units
inside the hospital and this is our current
incarnation current application for um how we show
the clinicians uh what is going on with their
patients based on on the data that are streaming
in now these estimates are based not only on the
ekg time series that that i showed you before
but actually everything that comes from the
bedside monitor which includes o2 saturations
blood pressures are arterial waveforms if they're
present and in addition we also use everything
that's in the ehr laboratory tests and vital signs
most systems of this kind restrict themselves
to what's in the ehr there's some theoretical
problems with that but we we use them too and
we add like i say the real time continuous aspect
to it as as well so let me go back to sharing here
i'm sorry i beg your pardon that's not what
i wanted let me go back to presenting here
okay so in our surgical icu which is where
we put the first of these displays in 2015
we counted heads in the six months before and
the six months after turning it on and we were
interested in outcomes there not a randomized
trial but was there an impact of outcomes and the
the the major result was that the rate of septic
shock so this is sepsis plus severe hypotension
fell by half after we turned on the display in
the medical icu nearby where there was no display
the incidence of septic shock remained much the
same there were some improvements and some other
outcomes it was a fairly large study but this was
the only one to reach statistical significance
it remains statistically significant after taking
age and illness severity into account as well so
good justification for further randomized trials
such as the one that i mentioned earlier now i'm
coming back let me come back to and finish
with with an observation about where where
all of this started this is recent work um and a
very high personal interest so all those years ago
we we based it all all everything that has
happened subsequently started when we looked
at this and said this is a signature of sepsis in
premature infants and now this is not a question
we asked ourselves back then and i'm glad we
didn't but looking back it's it's interesting to
think about how did we know that that was true and
now here's here's a modern question having asked
that question how do you even begin to figure
out whether you knew you were right or not okay
so enter a enter a technique called highly
comparative time series analysis so in 2013 doug
lake who might who i should have mentioned before
um reviewed a paper with with that title and for
the next several years was telling me what a good
idea this was and after a number of those years
it had finally it finally sunk in what he was
talking about we set forth together to try
with others to try to figure something out
highly comparative time series analysis
what is involved is or what it was in this
paper was the investigators took several
thousand time series from all sorts of origins
that they were able to find geology medicine
astrology anything that they could find
large time series and then did numerical
calculations on them they call them operations
using a very large number thousands in fact
of different kinds of mathematical operations
and when they come out of it they have millions
of results and they've used here rna arrays
uh sequence rna arrays to visualize the kinds
of results so this is a massively comprehensive
characterization of time series on a scale that
it took me a long time to understand what what
they were even talking about but with with doug
and with tim clark who in the school of data
science and school of public health we managed to
to get this done so here are the the the families
of mathematical operations a description and some
examples and we had amongst all of these things
2500 numerical algorithms that we could apply to
time series we applied them to two sets of time
series the heart rate and the oxygen saturation
in each time series was 300 points long so this is
a massive simply massive amount of of computation
so there i'm leaving out some of the intermediary
results to take you to the result that was most
directly relevant to to the point that
i brought up so here is a zoom call from
octa from a year ago and on the call or myself
karen fairchild who's a clinical neonatologist
and the engine for neonatology research in our
group over the past five years and more justin
niestroy a former math major at the university
of virginia now and also master's degree in data
science from the the university of virginia
at the time working in the group of tim clark
tim drinking that doesn't happen often but there
he is drinking and here is doug lake here and
the the result here is not so consequential but it
gives me a chance to say what we did so out of all
those algorithms we were able to turn to determine
those that were the best at characterizing
neonatal heart rate and oxygen saturation time
series that is to say we used an unsupervised
clustering technique and derived from it two
dozen measures that were that that as i say
covered the waterfront for characterizing the
dynamics and the distributions of heart rate
on one hand and oxygen saturation on the other
hand time series so we're now armed with a way
to look at all possible patterns of neonatal heart
rate so what we did was we took those two dozen
descriptors of neonatal heart rate dynamics
and prepared a logistic regression model
on the patients that were septic and then we
inspected the results with resp with regard to
what records did this new approach think were
associated with the highest risk of sepsis
in the next 24 hours and lo and behold here
they are these are 300 point heart rate time
series records discovered using an unsupervised
clustering method and then the results of that
in a logistic regression model on sepsis
and look what we have reduced variability
and decelerations these are the top 16 riskiest
records out of a very very large data set here we
have doug drinking and karen i didn't know she was
doing this but that was the first time i saw this
and it hit me like a ton of bricks that this was
the answer to the question how did we when how
did we know we were on the right track i don't
know but i but i am assured of that by this very
comprehensive mathematical analysis coming up with
exactly the same result so this is a figure that
that i made when the model predicting sepsis using
results of an unsupervised clustering technique
predicted highest risk reduced variability
decelerations when the model predicted lowest
risk high variability accelerations and then these
two records are at about the 50th percentile in
the 75th percentile or something like that they
are of diminishing risk as as we move across um
like that now the this there ends the most of
what i want to say about what we used to call
statistical pattern recognition what we now call
machine learning big data artificial intelligence
all the other things that that you know about
let me say that in in the in this field the new
frontier is understanding what to do with this
information and so i've listed a to-do list of
things that that begins with framing the clinical
questions that are of of importance to doctors and
nurses and ending with figuring out how to get
it distributed and and i will tell you every
step along that pathway we have we have we have
stumbled fallen sometimes picked ourselves up
sometimes not but this is what is required
to get from point from point a to point z
in this field i'm ending with this picture which
is a photograph that i took more than 10 years ago
of our group at work and it's to make the
point that this is not a job for some person in
isolation that this requires a multi-disciplinary
team of people working on it and this was not this
is obviously not rehearsed or opposed or staged
or any of those things but just to point out some
people this is john catwinkel for many years
the director of the of neonatology here and in
a world eminence in that field karen fairchito
fairchild i've already pointed out before hoshik
lee is a is a phd physicist was the postdoctoral
fellow of john the loss distinguished professor
of physics at william and mary matthew
clark at the time was a postdoctoral fellow
he's he was then the chief science officer at
amped and he's now principal engineer and nihon
coden brooke vergales is a clinical neonatologist
as is rob sinkin not shown in this in this picture
is doug lake but there's very much this
picture very very much this idea of a committed
collaborative group of clinical doctors and
quantitative scientists or data scientists
come together to communicate across a wide gap
to address a problem that's of importance to
patients and their families and the people
that take care of them at the bedside with
that i'll stop talking i'd be delighted to answer
questions and thanks again for the invitation
randall thank you so much for what an engaging
talk that was really wonderful and i was um i
i love that you've ended on this notion of team
science it really does take a village especially
when it's a very practical problem of that you're
trying to address and even in those cases where
it's a practical problem is that these things
aren't simple and you need experts from a number
of different domains to be able to address them um
i have a couple of questions for us to to get you
kind of started um so um you mentioned that these
a lot of this work comes from uh devices that sit
at the bedside of various patients and i'm kind
of curious if you explored like putting this on
to say taking it out of the away from the bedside
and into the community for example like on a smart
watch could something like this be something that
somebody could have running on their iphone watch
and you know be a sound an alarm should you
know somebody's heart rate uh descend into
some degree of you know the wrong end of the
entropy spectrum if you know what i mean well
so there's several interesting pieces of that um
and many of which we have not not touched on i
consider the the ambulatory monitoring problem to
be every bit as big or bigger than the in hospital
the impa hospital inpatient problem recall that
i pointed out as we went by that the positive
predictive value that is to say the probability
that an alarm is a true alarm it inevitably falls
as the as the rarity of the event increases
and so if you're out there monitoring everyone
for things that don't happen very often the very
very great majority of alarms are going to be
false alarms now this is being tested out there
because they're atrial fibrillation detection
algorithms built into apple watches now and there
are other ways other other kinds of things as well
and atrial fibrillation very important clinical
diagnosis calls for you know in intensive
treatments um and i'm very interested to see how
how all of that is going going to work out i must
say i don't have any personal interest in going
after that market um because of i think the diff
the false alarm difficulty is going to be very
high so the other aspect of this that that i
wanted to comment on is the whole idea of alarms
in the first place so if you know that alarms are
going to be false i i wouldn't issue them it the
inpatient story is very much attuned to the idea
that you're looking for changes in risk people
come in sick they should get better people get
better they should stay better they shouldn't
get sick again and so the whole thinking of
the clinical team is very much are they okay are
they are they okay are they okay and the nicu it's
are they separate card they said big are they
septic so the idea that you've got something in
real time or it's refreshes every 15 minutes or
an hour or whatever but in reasonable real time
that's keeping you abreast of current events
and somebody that you know an awful lot about
that resonates strongly with me as a clinician as
a useful thing to do much more so than than the
ambulatory one you mentioned uh a fibrillation and
uh you know one of the uh big risks with people
who are an afib is an increased risk of stroke and
i'm curious if you've uh you mentioned eye watches
have this capability in them now i'm curious if
you've attempted to apply this to looking at afib
patients and their risk of stroke for example
in contrast to sepsis in in neonates you know
afib predicting stroke in cardiac patients for
example well there are steps in that direction
have been toward improved identification
of atrial fibrillation from inpatient data
from the inpatient ekg telemetry so we did this
work a few years ago we have you know we applied
our time series interest towards this it's not
the hardest thing in the world to diagnose and
it's foiled by a few things like premature beats
but we worked hard on this and developed what i
think is a very nice algorithm for detection of
atrial fibrillation given an ekg recording so
we went back in our records and and found that
there was a lot of undiagnosed atrial fibrillation
in our intensive care units in fact about half of
the atrial fibrillation that occurred in the icu
in patients that didn't have it when they walked
in and weren't already you know on the radar but
about half of the new atrial fibrillation in the
ic use was not not commented on or acted upon by
clinicians and so to the end of detecting atrial
fibrillation so as to to start earlier diagnosis
and therapy that that is a great idea our
bandwidth is not extended clinically to be
able to do something about that although i
think that picture may may be changing soon
in in uh with regard to uh detect or detection of
the risk of stroke we've not taken that additional
step we're at the find the atrial fibrillation
part later would come in larger studies did it how
to what extent was atrial fibrillation related to
stroke the real question and i think this actually
got addressed i think recently is if you do all
of that and then randomize patients to blood
thinners which is of course the stroke prevention
step that you take if you give them ambulatory
atrial fibrillation detection devices and when
atrial fibrillation is diagnosed randomize them
to blood thinner or no is there an impact on
the stroke rate there's a recent study that had
no that had a negative result and said the stroke
rate was the same i don't know everything i need
to know about that but that at least is the is the
ultimate design or that is the design of the study
to answer the ultimate question that you just that
you know the way that you've brought it up what
do you think some of the current or kind of like
just more immediate challenges exist what are some
longer term challenges that need to be overcome
and where can data science continue to play a role
i well the two things so so my advice to the
to the young data scientists is go find a
young clinician who is obsessed with a clinical
problem for which early detection might lead to
therapies that can improve outcomes and you will
be codependent clinicians are too busy to go do
all of the programming required programmers
do not have their hands around the nuances and
complexities of of clinical medicine
i'll say with specific regard to
machine learning models in health care there's
a there's i have a lot of questions these days
and i mentioned this going through about relying
only on the electronic health record as a source
of data and the reason for that is that it very
much reflects in addition to the patient and the
illness it very much reflects the clinician and
the health system and the decisions that they
make the diagnoses that they're entertaining
and the policies of the hospital so imagine that
that what a patient it is admitted to the hospital
with shortness of breath and an abnormal chest
x-ray one clinician might very reasonably think
well this is decompensated heart failure and order
blood tests and medications that relate to that
another clinician might also reasonably make the
diagnosis of pneumonia and go off on a completely
different attack now the the data that those
clinicians gather will be very different from
each from one from the other because of their
their diagnosis or their assist their working
diagnosis and so they'll be investigating
different aspects of the patient and the idea that
you have colorized the patient and filled in all
the dots on the invisible man so that you can now
make out that form distinctly is is just is just
not right it doesn't work that way and so i worry
about approaches you that use only ehr because of
incompleteness inaccuracy and and this is supposed
to be about ethical and equitable ai believe me
there are issues about the way patients get worked
up in hospitals based on their race and ethnicity
and that will inevitably play into the data sets
that you have to analyze that brings me to kind of
a final question is are there communities in the
us or internationally where a technology like this
might be really helpful for addressing things
like for example infant mortality rates
well i i i think that a harder question
would be is there a hospital in the u.s
that doesn't need to figure out some way to use
all the data that they've got on their patients
absolutely individualized predictions um i again
now would that change the infant mortality rate of
the u.s i don't know how to answer that would it
change the mortality rate of premature infants and
neonatal icus in the u.s without question there's
a large randomized trial that says exactly that
that's fantastic well with that randall thank
you so much we really appreciate you sharing
with us this uh important work that uh
you're doing and have been doing and the
the work of your team uh you are a good
representative of uh all their efforts
and uh thank you so much for contributing to
our seminar series um everyone uh thank you
so much for for taking part and everyone have a
great weekend and we'll look forward to seeing